oh yeah folks get ready to be happy
because we are about to go on a ride
through the glory days old and new this
guy is a brother to me family and I love
a man plus he's in a really good place
and we had a great time hanging out so
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
Bam Margera yeah Mon what up dude I'm
super psyched man so first off what we
got going on business-wise I understand
there's a big merch drop this week is
that right yeah Johnny from element has
been working on some new stuff and you
know we had the band March going on in
Estonia but um I never saw any money
coming so five years of that I was like
you know what um so johnny from element
just took over so we'll see some results
soon with all the merch coming from
Estonia to people or do you have a place
here or do you even know it was all
coming from Estonia I bought a 3d
printing company like a whole big 3d uh
you know to make rings and things like
that and and because I was living there
for about two years and and when I went
home you know I couldn't keep up with
who was selling what so I had to cancel
that yeah I remember seeing a number of
comments on like social media people
saying yo I ordered this jewelry and it
never showed up probably you know I have
no idea and what's even worse this kid
that you had running that [ __ ] he would
flood your Instagram with promotion for
it but you wouldn't see it because he
would post something
to your feed let it like run its course
and then he would delete it so if you
looked at all of your profile it
wouldn't look out of the usual but
everybody watching it come through the
feed
they were slammed it was like BAM with
the [ __ ] merge already for God's eggs
and he would ask everybody who like I am
so she if I had a picture with post
Malone then he would blow up post
Malone's Instagram I asked him to do it
like a March post ballon ring or
something acting like it's coming from
you yeah and I was I didn't catch on
until like he did it to everybody or did
you say he was the guy he said let's do
a collab you guys know each other but I
always forget to introduce him he's my
co-host over here so uh how are people
buying this new legit and official
emerge I think it's got all going
through element now I can't just good
it's called hearts apply it's like a
side thing from element disjoining
Schiller Johnny Schiller F is the guy
who who's founded element didn't they
sell the company to like Quicksilver
Billabong Billabong yeah okay and that's
a skateboard company for which you were
a professional skateboarder before jack
has ever even came out and when jackass
did come out holy [ __ ] did you sell some
[ __ ] for element definitely yeah I was
selling more than Tony Hawk at one point
I'm I got asked for two years straight I
think it was over 20,000 skateboards a
month yeah it's [ __ ] awesome and this
so now when when the first season of
Jackass when we did that I think it's
interesting because people people
believe that we were all just like
Burroughs forever
when in fact we were not even all in the
same place and the show was already a
hit and we were filming the second
season I know totally I think the whole
first season we haven't even met yet
right right 100% the first time you guys
met each others on the diving board I
was in Orlando there the first time we
ever met was like at a hotel there and I
think that the first day I met you
ah we're at this hotel in Orlando which
we filmed that
firkin from the TV show the first movie
the second movie that and always the
same hotel they let us do whatever the
[ __ ] we want it became hotel Jackie as
pretty much that we've ruled this hotel
Bob we may walk around naked
interrupting like you know conferences
and they wouldn't even they just let us
do whatever we wanted a hundred percent
we had like God like big hole in the
wall to do the [ __ ] the boxing glove
comes through yeah that box said that
that was supposed to be Mike Tyson on
the other side of the wall but they
couldn't end up getting I said they just
did it with like a robotic arm but dude
it was in that same hotel oh my god do I
have a [ __ ] crazy story for that
hotel too but I think it was like as
soon as you checked in you guys went
into the little [ __ ] Fitness gym and
started turning on the treadmill and
[ __ ] destroying that treadmill oh
yeah yeah we were doing like skate
tricks on the treadmill and then we put
a bike on it yeah and we reused it until
it got destroyed
that was your crew doing that like you
and done yeah yeah and were you guys
like [ __ ] these guys are already filming
and killing it oh my god I was so
jealous of BAM like all the time and I
was just like [ __ ] that's something I
just never would have thought of you
know so they just came out right off the
bat just filming [ __ ] like [ __ ] it we
came here to show up so dude I mean the
first season of Jackass is totally a hit
right I still haven't met Bam but we're
on TV we're like [ __ ] famous and [ __ ]
and I had not seen
his video CK y2k which is just like this
how many copies did you sell of that
over a million oh my god I don't doubt
it I don't doubt it at all and and
meanwhile the whole time leading up to
this all I can think about is how can I
get into like a legitimate scape video
which is like then there's BAM who is
like how can I make my own entire scape
video and set up my own distribution and
sell a [ __ ] million copies of it BAM
was so far ahead of me and so I'm like
this one day I'm at my buddy's house and
and and I'm we're all tripping on liquid
acid we like dropped like liquid like
drops of liquid acid in dormouse
tripping our [ __ ] faces off the
students in his bedroom he's got a chick
in there filming a porno he's just
banging this chick and I'm sitting in
his living room tripping my face off
watching CKY 2k and I'm just just
becoming so jealous of the Pam and I'm
just like I saw Pam jump off this sixth
floor balcony of a hotel and I'm just
like so I'm like [ __ ] I go I'm banging
on the guy's jaw like dude your pornos
over we're [ __ ] come on we're going
so jealous or BAM got my stilts we went
to this bridge and I'm walking on stilts
tripping on acid and I throw myself over
the railing of the bridge which was a
hundred percent inspired by you
what video was that heard on that I
didn't get hurt boy was that I was like
knee surgery just waiting to happen and
I have to say this too since I saw a
comment from somebody they said dude I
love you steve-o your podcast is great
you got all these great guests but dude
with the [ __ ] talking about yourself
all the time I mean ask the guest a
question let them talk a [ __ ] he says
it's like every week it's the guest is
[ __ ] steve-o he got me so let me ask
you some questions I got paid per bit
not per episode for the first season of
Jackass and I had a pay scale that was
set up if it was a [ __ ] gnarly stunt
that you could get really [ __ ] hurt I
got five
bucks per bit and if it was like not
something that you could get hurt it's
like a prank or some just goofy thing
that you did in the street then I got
200 bucks so all told after taxes the
entire first season of jackass
I made less than $1,500 at there I'm
dying to know what your pay skill was
you got a love band you asked the guy a
question and he tells you the answer
even if it gets him in trouble and I'm
gonna tell you something right now that
might get me in trouble because this
episode of wild ride with steve-o is
sponsored by my favorite company that I
have been introduced to since I started
doing this and I know that a lot of the
other sponsors probably don't want me to
say that but it's true this product is
called hello tushy and the reason it
sounds a little bit
echoey is because I'm in the upstairs
bathroom at my house where it is set up
Hiller - she is a bidet that means it
sprays water onto your [ __ ]
okay I'm gonna go ahead and show you how
it works like normally my [ __ ] is in
the line of fire but oh okay oh yeah
that's how it works now I have this
crazy relationship with my [ __ ] right
like I'm used to wiping and wiping and
wiping like like paranoid and like I'm
like why am I still saying it was I
wiped my way and I still think after I
get done wiping then I'm gonna have to
wipe again sometimes I actually do but
now that I use hello - she this bid day
like it blasts my [ __ ] the only
reason I even use toilet paper at all
afterwards is for the satisfaction of
seeing that there is ZERO poo on it at
all man plus it helps you ah with your
health here I can have hemorrhoids not
gonna have like crazy like infections
what else
incredibly good for the environment
instead of going through all this toilet
paper I mean dude this is my favorite
product and if you go - hello - she
dot-com slash steve-o
you can get 10% off your order and I'm
telling you you're gonna thank me for it
it is almost too good to be true you
know why it's not because it is true so
go ahead and get yourself a hello Trisha
bidet at hello tushy comm / Steve oh and
get 10% off your order I think I think
it was something like four grand an
episode but I could be wrong I suspect
you had like five I don't know where I
got that idea like five maybe they
acquired a bunch of footage from you as
well BAM right yeah they took the whole
first CKY video and you know just mixed
it in with the Big Brother stuff that
they were doing right let me introduce
Paul another artist yeah that was Paul
Brisky he's a gorgeous guy he's off
camera right now got a huge dick
we called him young [ __ ] and he's my
editor oh my god let me ask some other
questions got some information out of
the guest for once what the [ __ ]
happened to your website do that I
remember your website was Bam Margera
with only one M and I wanted to prepare
for this conversation so I just logged
on to your website and it's some [ __ ]
[ __ ] selling scooters in Estonia I
think the street team needs to get on
this hey I got a question so so you sold
a million copies of CKY right okay yqk
was that before jackass or like how was
that hustle like some other cars yeah
but before he had out for it or anything
so you know it was just pure profit yeah
it was the distribution was through just
mom-and-pop skate shops but it was with
an actual distributor right where was it
Tom Nieto in the beginning and then I
went to VA s on distribution which was
also with Elliman for one one yeah oh my
god how many copies did you sell before
jackass hit
do you remember with CKY one close to a
million yeah right and and there was
like a shady business deal on that one
he was trying to like help out this
[ __ ] wheel company called land speed
and then they took all the money and
never paid him man seems like it like
there's been more than a couple people
who have taken advantage of you I don't
like it
oh there's 90 grand on that one and they
said that there was no money cuz I never
thought I would get a lawyer and I did
you know I was like 17 years old he's
not gonna get a lawyer so I got one and
turned out that they made 90 grand and
never paid anything wow that seems like
90 grand seems like there's not enough
but dude I mean didn't give a [ __ ] about
90 grand he was killing it so much and
in if it was five thousand bucks per
episode on jackass that was [ __ ]
compared to all see that's the thing he
had revenue streams in place when jack
ass kicked he had the skateboards the
[ __ ] shoes and then the Tony Hawk
video game how old were you when jackass
popped off 20 about 18 I think your
doober 20 because I'm six years older
okay yeah yeah 20 yeah and it said sound
like we're all going to bars and Bam's
not legal age to drink my god so crazy
and then consider that he was already at
least in skateboarding a full [ __ ]
star from like the age of like 13 like
Howard read me first got sponsored 13
with Furman skate shop just the local
skate shop around town and then when I
was 16 that's when I got sponsored by
eighth Street which became evolve which
is love backwards
vol it's an eighth Street man God that
when did Plan B come around they came
around right when 8th Street turned to
Eve all but yeah they and they came out
with a huge video questionable that was
like the best video for sure um did so
the sir this is how how totally intense
BAM is
when jackass was just a TV show and
meanwhile like dude I was a [ __ ]
cocaine addict I was [ __ ] broke I'm
[ __ ] homeless
I got nothing and Bam's over at the Audi
dealership [ __ ] can't figure out
which of two cars he likes best so he
buys both that's her true story you
bought two Audi's at once yeah not at
once but close to close together
yeah I really wanted the s4 but I bought
the a4 when I could afford it and then
instantly I got more money so now and
bought the s4 in the garo blue thank God
was that was that season one money I was
like element money in 401 money mostly
CKY videos and stuff yeah when you say
season 1 money season 1 of jaga's was
just the engine that drove the whole
machine which was just you know like
jackass was the rocket ship on his
pre-existing revenue stream yeah it was
getting that because he bought that off
season 1 money and you just made $1,500
or something yeah I was homeless I was
unemployed I was [ __ ] broke it was it
was it was and then I [ __ ] drove
cross-country so now I don't have a
place to live so I'm just hanging out in
the [ __ ] TV offices that they had for
jackass play in LA yeah and then it was
just like this TV office and I'm just
like [ __ ] picking my ass hanging out
right now a list of nevermind
and bam comes into town and and he's
like dude [ __ ] how am I gonna put
together 2.5 million dollars to [ __ ]
fund my own movie to make Haggard rise
that exact sound right and I was yeah
and I was just like what 22.5 what
million how much copies of Haggard did
you sell it definitely was worth doing
but it wasn't like a it wasn't like the
CKY videos I guess people want to see
like raw stunts and things like that you
know as soon as you turn it into a Sunni
where you're rehearsing lines and things
like that
skateboarders don't dig that too much
but it has a cult following right it's a
good sense kind
like saying actionpoint wasn't like yeah
the hit that jackass was what was your
first impression of Steve when you met
him I was honestly uncomfortable with
Scott asking that question because I was
terrified of what Bam's answer was gonna
be but you know what's not uncomfortable
everything going on in my jeans you know
why because Mac Weldon makes their own
fabric and they are the one-stop shop
for all your men's basics underwear
socks shirts hoodies even raincoats
telling any man I had the best
experience at Mac Weldon dot-com putting
together my order getting the comfiest
premium men's products all of my
underwear and socks and everything and I
am just thrilled to let you know that if
you go to Mac Weldon dot-com and use the
promo code steve-o you will get 20% off
your first order again that's 20% off
your first order
when you go to Mac Weldon calm and use
the promo code steve-o you're gonna
thank me I mean take care of yourself
guys live in comfort Mac well dinner
yeah dude
was that the first time in the hotel
room do you know about him being worried
I just thought he was gnarly cuz every
time we were there was never a dull
moment you know what I mean like there
was always something going on there's
always something there's always a camera
in front of our faces all the time so
there we were just at it non-stop you
know filming deer I was so [ __ ]
impressed with bam dude and like one of
the first things we did when he was in
Orlando that we met and this was like
for this like this epic you know first
time we all got together when they built
this the loop you know like one of the
first days [ __ ] Bam's doing the loop
with Tony Hawk right he pulled the loop
in like on jackass I I didn't do it on
jackass that was the first time I tried
it and I was I came pretty close but I
but I ate [ __ ] so I
stop trying it and then a year later I
tried it again a Bob Burnquist house and
I was so close to doing it until I
pulled a Brian Schaeffer and I did a 360
slammed right on my head I got the wind
knocked out of me so I waited another
year and in Phoenix Arizona is where
they had the Tony Hawk
boom boom hooked him and I tried it
there and I did it first try
now like from the very beginning of
Jackass with all the like in seeing
success and all like the selling of
skateboards like you weren't known so
much for the harder gram and I was
listening to to your nine club podcast
and they asked did you have a business
agreement with the band him to like use
the hard a gram and you said that there
was some kind of agreement but then they
sold it to Warner Brothers like what's
what's the business behind the hard a
gram that was another thing that
elements sorted out they started making
BAM are two grand boards and I guess
they figured out a deal with them but
once they they got bought by Warner
Brothers for four million dollars then
it it became a whole new thing like they
would argue they would get pissed that I
had a harder gram on my front door of my
house during people of BAM like look
people were starting to think that the
whole grand Yours I'm like dude I'm just
promoting my favorite band like right
underneath that's all I'm doing it's I'm
putting their symbol out everywhere
hopefully people will catch on that this
is a band that I like from Finland you
know just so that people are aware of
what we're talking about the band was
called him and the band's symbol was the
hard a gram and he said the Warner
Brothers bought the band where the the
Warner Brothers signed with Warner
Brothers and and so Warner Brothers
owned their catalog or something yeah I
guess so when they're strict about
everything too and dude you were pretty
[ __ ] over-the-top when it came to
being a fan of him I mean for them to
complain about you is
yeah that's the only reason I know of
the band him is probably through you a
lot of people say yeah 100%
whatever happened the singer of him
Villa valo
just like iconic guy man like true rock
star dude but I haven't heard anything
about what's up with them in a long time
is him still together
I don't know what happened but no they
broke up I guess they were making their
seventh album and it started to sound
just like all the other albums and you
know they just decided to you know shut
the lock and throw away the key and and
now everybody is doing their own thing I
know that a half band gasps and Lindy
the guitar player started a new band
called flat earth and solo stuff that's
cool now since we're on the topic of
music dude I'm such a fan I've told you
this again and again George
you made this album that is so [ __ ]
good like you know you've had a bunch of
different music projects right like what
was your first one was it Nora kill not
kill yeah and then then we did [ __ ]
unstoppable and then we did eavesdropper
yeah yeah yeah eavesdroppers is a
[ __ ] unbelievable album and like I've
texted you this I've told you this over
and over and I just don't understand how
this album hasn't gotten the the
recognition that it deserves
like I mean BAM sings on it this is yeah
in Europe and remember I came up on the
top and I was like damn this is sick who
is this this is Bam's band I was like
BAM and you're like yeah he's singing
him like he's singing that like
completely and like I mean walk us
through it did you put together like a
crazy all-star cast of musicians and it
was just like a [ __ ] dream team of
like and and it was an expensive ass
album to make right it was yeah probably
50 grand I spent on that and you know I
I didn't even put it out all night
I don't think so do the fees for
godsakes and every I know that this
episode that we're recording right now
is gonna be wildly popular because it's
[ __ ] Bam Margera and people love us
together
everybody listening please tell them how
to get a copy of this eavesdroppers
album because it is so good
awesome having my brother
you know meet up with Bam's brother at
the 7-eleven wah wah I mean for God's
sakes dude there's got to be a way man
and I will get this up this week man
like I'm afraid with some with
everything going on in the world I'm
afraid to like record a podcast like too
far in advance because who knows the
world might explode with BAM you're man
of many hidden talents and what
surprised me the most when we camping
was that I learned that you have a you
have a kind of like a secret talent for
knowing all the world capitals yeah you
people know that about you I guess some
people what's the capital of Somalia
Somalia is Mogadishu then Ethiopia Addis
Abeba
it throughout a country Indonesia
Indonesia Jakarta think of a country
yeah Canada okay right he's gotta be a
great one more what do we got a Estonia
dystonia Tallinn dude Wow when did you
learn all that I realized that I only
had to learn like 20 more to say I
officially know all the capitals so I
just wrote it on a shoebox in my car and
I kept looking at it when I was driving
and it's kind of like you know with
other people songs you know like sweet
child of mine
Oh Guns N'Roses you know like that's how
I know when you say you know Finland oh
he'll spin them he'll sink you you know
it's like um understand man Oh Metallica
you know that's that's how easy it is
for me wow that's great I'm glad you
brought that up didn't know you had that
up your sleeve
yeah well I kept I didn't either right I
remember I kept like throwing him out on
the whole weekend and he never missed
one it's so great how many countries
have you been to do you know I've been
everyone pretty much I never been to
Africa yet but uh and I may be like all
the stands like I've never been to
Pakistan Afghanistan Turkmenistan Curtis
ah that you've been to every other one
what's that what do you know how many
countries you've been do because there's
like a hundred and ninety of them I
would say probably half that's [ __ ]
incredible
were you just in Mongolia no never been
to Mongolia what's the capital of
Mongolia
well I'm but or so
may I real I can't get over the fact
that we don't have a distribution for
this [ __ ] album like this is this is
a habit and something that I don't do
enough I really wish I did but I'll just
decide on an album commit to it and I
listen to it over and over and over so
that for the rest of my life whenever I
hear it again it'll take me back to that
time when I was listening to it and when
I was here your [ __ ] album the
eavesdroppers album like it takes me to
touring through Europe on Justin
Bieber's tour bus with Scott Randolph
day and it was such a great time yeah
such a great time eunbi restore bus he
was the last guy to like [ __ ] rent
the tour bus for a tour before us I mean
whatever now it's like speaking of like
big celebrities we see you with post
Malone all the time you were talking to
the 9 Club people and instead BAM
casually mentions like so I texted lil
wayne cuz like super into skateboarding
yeah yeah he's an East Coast guy too
right little Wayne yeah he's from New
Orleans but he lives in Miami now here's
like a half pipe on his like pen
our suite in Miami he just put out like
a music project Lil Wayne and like it
was just a vehicle for him to put his
skateboard and footage into it did you
see I did see it and he's going for it
man yeah if it's safe to say that you're
the best skater out of all the Jackass
guys yeah handedly is the only one that
was pro oh really
for sure who was the second-best yeah
second bass Adam we murder Steve no no
no no I probably we man but it's like
pretty close between Dave England and
Chris Pontius well over second-best
skateboarding's a subjective thing you
know you can't really it's apples and
oranges but Chris had the [ __ ] south
flip on mini ramps yeah yeah crazy
though being 40 and and you just lose
your tricks man like I had a bag of
tricks and now I only have like a bag of
ten if I'm lucky I've been [ __ ]
skating hard and I know exactly what you
mean dude it's dude I know like my
balance is off and it's just crazy like
it's a cliche question but like what
kind of do you have like aches and pains
and [ __ ] from like certain things yeah
from all the injuries like from just
skating in jackass they all they all
kicked in at 40 I got a twisted ankle
right now I can barely walk
ah dude and leg but but there's no like
like one like chronic bit like where
you're like [ __ ] it's my back hurt like
okay I just follow my thumb it was my
hamstring I was out for a year from that
right yeah I'm a bit or from just the
trick or a skating just probably skating
I'm in my barn I pulled a hamstring and
it took a year to heal yeah do you have
no gray hair yet I got some beard
yeah I'm sporting it man I'm like this
is my Corona afro and I'm just letting
it ride dude I never thinking like five
years ago I was thinking about get
my hair I was like really good should I
do it man said dude should I get [ __ ]
like just for men and dye it so glad I
didn't I'm just rockin it that's so fun
let's get old as hell I remember what I
remember the first time like or like the
first year I started working with Steve
he like came out of the came out of his
bedroom or something with like a
childhood picture he was like eight and
then he was like okay look at this and
he's like you see a difference in the
hairline like no dude now let's give the
people some jackass [ __ ] man like you
know I'm trying to think I remember a
time when you had your purple
Lamborghini and we were filming jackass
number two and they thought it'd be real
funny if they would wouldn't they put in
it like a [ __ ] life or after that
sailfin from one of those instant blowup
life rafts they decided to put in the
Lamborghini and dude you could barely
fit like a [ __ ] Mountain Dew in there
you know what I mean like so when that
thing blew up it cracked the windshield
and cracked the sight like it did some
substantial damage to it like they
rented me a Bentley until it got fixed
for that if you [ __ ] put a scratch in
the paint of a Lamborghini that's like
gonna be 30 grand and [ __ ] get it
touched up or some [ __ ] it's great like
I left the gas cap and a gas station by
accident and I'm like all right yeah
that sucks whatever I'll get another one
was a 50 bucks no if it's a thousand
dollars for a little a gas and and I
remember hearing that like that like
Lamborghini and by definition is a
sports car which means it's stick shift
but is it true that you had them like
customize your Lamborghini to make it
automatic because he didn't want to deal
with stick shift no it came with a year
which you you you shift on the paddles
of the of the steering wheel but there
is no clutch
it was there any stunts that BAM did
were you like [ __ ] I'm jealous of that
like on a jackass movie I once had
anything that stands out though my main
thing that I was jealous of BAM was that
he he did it all he kept skating and for
me like I was a grew up a skater but I
was just like man I'm not that good at
skating I want to be in skateboard
videos but I'm just gonna not skate and
I'm gonna do the [ __ ] up crazy [ __ ]
that they pack into skateboard because
even skateboarders would get bored of
watching like an hour of skateboarding
you know I like it they always had to
break it up by putting crazy [ __ ] in
there and that was what BAM and I
specialized in but BAM skated too and I
just wish I would have never quit yeah I
feel the same way when I was filming
Viva La Bam you know I would I used to
skate five hours a day and then Wendy
will abandon you know there's 40 people
and payrolls so you know you can't spend
the whole day skateboarding or else you
won't get your footage you know for an
episode so by five hours of skating
every day slowly turned into two to one
to thirty to none
BAM do you have a favorite Viva La Bam
episode that you did probably the Civil
War when we had 200 Civil War
Reenactment people come to the house and
battle it out who's just fun because you
know they were camping outside and it
felt like it was the you know 1800s
whatever it was like yeah it was rad or
turning the house into a skate park
do they still play Viva La Bam I think
they still played jackass episodes
everywhere DJ stop doing deal Alabam
maybe a couple years ago did you ever
like get like ongoing residual checks
for Jack as the TV show or Viva La Bam
or anything um I think for the movies of
Jack yeah the movies it's crazy man dude
I saw AMC Theaters it's like on the
verge of bankruptcy you're gonna [ __ ]
what if there's no moving theaters
well I think Amazon
gonna buy them all out [ __ ] how crazy
with that fellow really crazy I mean
it's a crazy time man I've been a little
bit candid on on on this [ __ ] podcast
deal about how we were one weekend of
filming jackass four and then boom they
just shut it down
mm-hmm have you heard yeah we've been on
hiatus for how long two and a half
months or something right so now like I
was with our sound guy Cordell this
morning surfing and he said they're
talking about firing it back up in like
late August and I'm like dude so we'll
be like [ __ ] right like one week into
filming again and then the second wave
of the [ __ ] coronavirus is gonna shut
this fall when we got a time you're
gonna get this movie done that's what
they're saying in the middle of August I
heard that's a Cordell told me this
morning a turn and [ __ ] no yeah Steve
I remember you had a video of you guys
were all partying at your house and like
you were pulling Bam's pants off or
something like Jacob do you remember
partying at Steve's old apartment like I
wasn't there for that but was that just
a wild [ __ ] timer there was footage
of like that there was some night
Knoxville
he had like a doorbell thing that was
like there's a setup to like explode in
your face and he wanted me to dress up
as a clown I'm in clown makeup and then
we ended up back at my apartment Bam's
all drunk what year was this 2006 and
remember I stripped you naked while you
were like passed out drunk and I'm like
huh BAM you were like ha ha ha I never
shared that anywhere you never show that
how come I saw you just had it load it
was a back it was in that paparazzi
stopped me on video that I never put out
I put out bits of it on YouTube
do you remember partying at Steve's old
apartment yeah
Sergey do you do do you have a youtube
channel I think this is important this
is important because like I like what I
have this is this YouTube operation
again the guy up front Paul we call him
young [ __ ] he's my editor and like I've
got thousands of videotapes like all
these hard drives remember you're at the
house he saw these
car drives like their and what I do is I
come up with like okay what's a video
that like would be like a cool like
story to tell and it's like like the
tattoos I regret the most
and then we film it we put put it
together and there was like the one I
showed you when you came over did this
one got taken off of YouTube and they
got me in trouble with YouTube it was
the the best wake up pranks of jackass
and wild boys okay and because it
involved like smacking people who are
asleep like doing like means [ __ ] to
wake people up while they're sleeping by
definition because they're asleep
they're not a willing participant so
it's like without consent assaulting
somebody who's not okay with it and like
even though we could show all that [ __ ]
on MTV I put it on YouTube but I got in
trouble but it's just an example and I
know you have so much footage for like
from your whole life since you were
[ __ ] like eight probably like just to
imagine the kind of stories the videos
that you could tell I mean do I did 26
straight weeks every week yeah every
week a proper new video and I didn't
even really have to do anything it was
just like oh like let me let me [ __ ]
put together some old footage in a way
that tells a new story you know I think
you could do so well with that you could
just do so well with that there's so
much like so much footage though that
it's overwhelming right but that's why
if you just take a bite-sized chunk you
know your leg inch-by-inch life's a
cinch yard by yard life is hard and
you've been talking a lot about this
like this this documentary this new BAM
movie I know that like it was driving
you crazy like trying to get it right
and working on and working on it like
what's the status of that one I just had
to let it go I was working on it way too
hard and I kept changing it it should
have been something that was like an
eight-episode thing and I kept trying to
squeeze all this
into two hours and I just slowly
destroyed it you know I just kept
changing it and changing it and changing
it
I remember you showing me a draft of it
like on the night where we lit my balls
on fire line with my jeans we [ __ ]
spray it if we lit my crotch on fire and
then you put it out kicking me in the
nuts which was just great and I remember
that was the night where you showed it
to me and it was great to tell the tell
the story but like it just ended up
where it was like yeah and then now like
my [ __ ] feet are fractured or that I
can't you know like it needed somebody
like it needed like a triumphant like
happy ending was what I meant that it
was missing and thank God were [ __ ]
ready to just you know get the band back
together do our thing you know
it's for Sam I'm stoked that I didn't
get to see too much like I was one week
that we were filming and of course we
can't give away anything that happened
but I can assure everybody that BAM
showed up [ __ ] ready to work you know
I was super stoked when we did that one
thing you know like that one violent
fucked-up disturbing thing BAM I
remember like you were a little nervous
about it but zero hesitation for any of
us and we just marched right into the
[ __ ] worst situation dude what's a
day during the pandemic look like for
you are you keeping busy I see you're
working out with Novak and oh yeah yeah
I work out with Novak in the trainer
every other day and I got a twisted
ankle now but I would skate the barn as
much as I could and earn that just going
bike riding trails I got trails all in
the backyard like that go to the next
town over so it's all good just trying
to exercise as much as possible are you
enjoying the pandemic or you kind of
want to give that out I can't wait for
it to end
it's
yeah have you been live you've been like
taking it seriously like you go out and
you're wearing your mask and you're
being careful to stay away from people
and [ __ ] yeah I mean I'm try to but once
you get to the skate barn there's 20
people in there then you know it kind of
all goes away then you go back to
Westchester it's like back to reality
with the mask again everywhere right I
saw you doing the protesting tear like
where to like was it thousands of people
all jammed in like in the streets yeah
yeah there was a lot of people for the
black lives matter thing that's good man
I'm sure you're pretty recognizable even
with the mask on it's weird at the
grocery store I am but nobody really
recognized me on the March so it feels
good yeah what did you have there Paul
well I was just saying I've been meaning
to ask you this but this goes for both
of you being sort of like [ __ ] it badass
like we're not scared of [ __ ] guys your
whole lives now it's this everyone's
asking to wear masks to be careful to
wash your hands and it's like you know
is it does it go against all your nature
to like put that mask on and sort of
like be careful I can answer that it was
just us we wouldn't give a [ __ ] but
we've always been really careful not to
bring innocent by standards third party
people into our [ __ ] right like you
don't want to do a stunt and [ __ ]
land on like the innocent guy walking by
on the street so by that same measure
you wouldn't want to catch the virus and
then pass it on to some [ __ ] like
innocent elderly person you know so out
of respect for other people we try not
to [ __ ] pass that [ __ ] around cool
makes sense
yeah yeah it's funny I was laughing
earlier because I when I said you know
are you recognizable with the masks and
I remember Steve and I went to a Comic
Con or some [ __ ] he was like he was
like yo dude like he's like I want to go
as a stormtrooper so people don't
recognize me so I don't have to take all
these [ __ ] pictures it's like a
YouTube convention and we get in there
and [ __ ] everybody wanted to take a
picture with a stormtrooper
he probably took like 200 photos as a
stormtrooper big time when's the last
time you went like a skateboard
convention or anything like that it's
been a long time yeah dude what I am but
I just do all the festivals of like the
summer of music festivals they're all
shut down because of corona like dude
there's so much money being [ __ ] I
dig that stuff you know like my Lakers
stadium tour was sold out why they had
stadiums sold out 50,000 plus they have
Motley Crue with poison and Joan Jett
and [ __ ] yeah Def Leppard yeah yeah
it's crazy dude it's crazy
back on track though man what's it like
being a dad dude it's cool yeah he's
two-and-a-half now starting to say
sentences which is cool mom where's Yap
bring him over when did it hit you like
oh [ __ ] I'm a dad did yeah I mean well
he was totally planned in Barcelona is
weird the only time kid man can you say
something can you say can you say [ __ ]
[ __ ] what's your favorite bad word BAM
are you worried he's gonna grow up and
watch CKY and start coming in while
you're trying to take a [ __ ] and messing
with you and stuff like you always doing
to fail yeah you can't be mad at it when
it happens but it's probably gonna
happen
yeah it's getting good footage I guess
so do you have any more like music
projects dude like more like another
[ __ ] eavesdroppers albums I'm telling
you man like get that [ __ ] out there man
you know like if you put 50 green into
it it's that seems to me like a mellow
investment I think that album is worth
so much dude I love it
about 7 songs that never made it to that
album so I already have 7 songs together
or done I'll tell you what let's like
when we wrap this up here let's get on a
group text with your brother Jess and
figure out like hey how do we [ __ ]
get this you know like do you have a
right-hand man where you just throw [ __ ]
at and he [ __ ] handles for you I used
to but he moved to Richmond Virginia so
that ended I know that you were doing
like comedy clubs and stuff like that is
that something that like you're gonna
like when the pandemics over like are
you interested in getting back out on
tour and actually putting together like
a like a legit act oh I don't know it
was fun it was just like basically a Q&A
right with what the fans they were you
know and it was like a sit-down event
you know it it was fun but I don't know
if I'm gonna continue that I'm dying to
know is it a jackass thing or is it just
a steve-o thing or do you get the same
question do people always ask you what
stunts hurt the most or do you get
different sets of questions no that's a
question that everybody asks like I
think what hurt the most was probably I
was filming cribs with the Bloodhound
Gang and I and I was in a music video
driving this banana car and I drove the
banana car into this moat and when it
was sinking I did a gainer into the moat
because they said it was seven feet deep
it was only two feet two equally sharp
rocks and I split my head open with 16
staples so and I was like in and out of
consciousness on the way to the hospital
that was probably one for worse that's
[ __ ] dad that was for cribs yeah cribs
for cribs MTV shows dick like in such
graphic detail on an x-ray
to the bucket car hey so so you guys
have all seen each other naked all the
jackass dudes yeah who's got the biggest
dong out of all you guys honey I said
think right POTUS has the biggest dick
yeah
he's got the hammer yeah he's got the
war hammer but I think we're [ __ ]
good BAM Bam's trying to smoke a
cigarette like we could always [ __ ]
fire this up again but dude thank you so
much man so funny yeah cuz like I was
like late like you know I wanted to
really make this happen
and I wanted to make sure that so I
didn't even [ __ ] like message me a
bad message and thank him like hey we
gotta get BAM on this like it was that
smart was that the best best way yeah
you don't really pay attention to your
text messages and [ __ ] that much ah
not too much yeah hey I gotta tell you
man I [ __ ] I love you brother and I'm
like really glad to see you like just
like you know looking good you know I
like I feel like you're in a really good
place man and I'm just stoked about it
awesome yeah I really am stoked about at
night I just can't wait for us to if I
can get back to work man I know me too
I got the I got one of these shirts
where this guy made this [ __ ] killer
Ryan done shirt all right it's not
anything he sells I don't think but he
[ __ ] sent me a whole box albums for
everybody in the cast okay cool yeah so
I got any plans to come to LA we're all
locked down I'm just on lockdown until
they want me to write call me I look
forward to [ __ ] getting it back
together dude and if Nikki's right there
was like please let me tell her Thank
You Nikki for letting me badger you and
bother you to make sure that this
happened it totally worth it and I'm
super stoked yeah hey BAM before we go
what's the capital of uruguay uruguay is
yeah so happy to see bam in such a good
place i really mean that because it's no
secret that i've
kind of worried about him in recent
times and out today I'm not not worried
about him at all you know what else I'm
happy about is talking to you guys when
you have hung in there until the end of
the episode it's a big deal for me
and what I like to do is to ask you
folks to screenshot the podcast on
whatever you're listening to it on if
it's you're following a computer
whatever post that screenshot and tag me
tag bam to let them know that you listen
to the episode let them know that you're
rooting for them let them know that
you're happy to see him happy cuz
that'll mean a lot to me and when I say
tag me tag bam don't just put alright
handles in the captions we won't see
that and when when I see these posts
every time I throw like on that [ __ ]
most of the time I even throw a comment
and yeah man it's just like important to
me that I do that and that I thank you
guys for listening because I really do
appreciate it and I'm just gonna just
throw this out there I don't know if for
the people on YouTube I think that
[ __ ] algorithms mad at us or
something something's going on man
because they're not suggesting our
videos as much so always make sure you
watch to the end
throw the like the comment whatever man
let's get that algorithm rooting for us
alright enough out of me thanks guys I
love you